قال الرئيس دونالد ترامب ذات مرة إنه لا يوجد
شيء يخسره من خلال الترويج
لهيدروكسي كلوروكين كعلاج محتمل
لفيروس كورونا ، لكن بعض
ملايين الأمريكيين المصابين
بأمراض مزمنة مثل
الذئبة يقولون إن هناك بالفعل الكثير على
المحك وهناك نقص الآن في
الأدوية التي يستخدمونها  لقد كانت تأخذ
لسنوات عديدة قالت امرأة لشبكة CNN إنها
بحاجة إلى خفض جرعتها بينما
تنتظر وصول عبوة جديدة
من المملكة المتحدة ، وقالت
امرأة أخرى تحدثت إلى
آنا فالديز إنها اضطرت إلى
قبول حبوب منع الحمل من إحدى تمريضها.
الطلاب الذين قام آباؤهم بتخزين
الأدوية لأنهم اعتقدوا أنها قد
تحميهم من فيروس
كورونا ، استمع عندما أفتح هذا البريد الإلكتروني ،
بدأت على الفور في البكاء وكان
البكاء حقًا من الامتنان
لأنني علمت أنني لن أضطر إلى
الذهاب بدون دوائي
و  كنت أيضًا فخورة جدًا بممرضة الطالب الخاصة بي
لإدراكها للحاجة
ومحاولة تلبيتها ودعمي ، مما
جعلني أشعر بالفخر
لكوني ممرضة وشايًا.  يشعر هؤلاء الأمريكيون
بأنهم قد تركوا في مأزق وأن
الرئيس ترامب قد انتقل بالفعل
وفقًا لتحليل CNN الذي
أسقطه هيدروكسي كلوروكين
ما يقرب من 50 مرة منذ المسيرة قائلاً
إنه يفضل المخاطرة بالعقاقير غير المثبتة
إذا  يمكن أن ينقذ حياة الأمريكيين ، إنه أمر
رائع
بالنسبة للملاريا بالنسبة لمرض الذئبة لأشياء أخرى
وسنرى ما هو ولكن أعتقد
ديبورا أن لديهم العديد من الدراسات التي
تجري حول ذلك ، لذا
سنكون قادرين على التعلم هذا الأسبوع  تشير
دراسات جديدة في فرنسا
والبرازيل هنا في الولايات المتحدة إلى أن
الأدوية قد لا تكون فعالة في علاج
فيروس
كورونا وقد يكون لها مضاعفات قلبية قاتلة ،
ومع ذلك ظهرت سوق
سوداء ووفقًا لتقاريرنا ، فإن
البائعين على شبكة الإنترنت المظلمة يبيعون
الحبوب من أجلها.  ما يصل إلى 43 دولارًا ،
أي أكثر من المعدل المعتاد إذا
حصلت على وصفة طبية من طبيبك ،
فعادة ما يكون حوالي دولار واحد ،
لذا فإن الخلاصة هي تداعيات الحياة الحقيقية
لخطاب الرئيس ترامب  لا يزال
يتم التعامل معه من قبل بعض الأمريكيين الأكثر
ضعفا مارشال كوهين سي إن إن
واشنطن